hello my name is alex rodowa and today
i'll be talking about liquid and gas
chromatography mass spectrometry method
development for the quantification of
per and polyfloral alkyl substances in
environmental matrices
before we really start to dive in i just
wanted to give everyone an opportunity
to grab that contact information so if
you have any follow-up questions feel
free to reach out um so i'm right here
at the top alex rodoa i have also listed
two of my collaborators jessica reiner
and benjamin place who are also at nist
the national institute of standards and
technology
so a little bit of background about me
so i am currently a nrc postdoc with the
national institute of standards and
technology i started my postdoc in
november of 2019 in charleston south
carolina in the biochemical and exposure
sciences group
um so currently i'm working on pfas
which we're going to be talking about
extensively today and expanding the
knowledge that we currently have at nest
um so we i will be expanding the pfas
methodology and then working on
reference material production and
quantitative analysis of materials and
so we'll be talking about all of those
things and you'll get a little bit more
background before that i did my phd at
oregon state university also in pfas is
p fastest in different environmental um
matrices
so i've said the word pfas a lot um so
let's dive in tell me about pfas um so
there are a couple important things i
really like to mention early on in the
presentation for those of you that don't
know what pfas are
so firstly they're from anthropogenic
origin so pfas when we see them in the
environment are a direct result of human
use and disposal
and we only see them because they're
man-made and not naturally occurring
products we play them in numerous
sectors which is why we see them in the
environment so commonly so the sectors
include consumer products manufacturing
processes and in aqueous film forming
foams for the suppression of
hydrocarbon-based fuel fires we'll talk
about that a little bit today but if you
want any more information feel free to
reach out
again important to remember there are
potentially thousands of pfas and that's
a result of proprietary mixtures and
impure chemistries so let's talk about
those chemistries a little bit more
okay so here are the things that make
p-value fast so firstly they have a
carbon-fluorine chain so the
carbon-fluorine chain can vary in length
um as you can see so they can go from 2
all the way up to about 22.
of course there are some odd exceptions
here and there so you can see there
could be a number of different uh chain
lengths and so that would count as an
individual pfas the other thing we have
to consider is that all of these carbon
fluorine chain links may have different
appearances so right here in the middle
you see there could be linear which is
also what i've shown over here on the
left
there could also be branch pfas isomers
and so what that means is that the
molecular weight of the molecule is the
same but they are slightly smaller
surface area
and that's going to come up a little bit
later in one of our chromatographic
slides
so we've got the branch and linear we've
got this carbon fluorine chain link so
the that is shared by all pfas the thing
that can vary in a piece of is that
polar head group and so over here on the
right i've shown different examples of
what polar hood groups can look like um
so each of these polar head groups
typically have a distribution of chain
lengths associated with them and so you
can see how this problem is sort of
multiplying right so we have tons and
tons of different phases um the polar
head group may vary the chain length may
vary and it all sort of contributes to
the p fast problem so
i wanted to um just for the purposes of
this presentation give you a bit of a
better representation so the carbon
fluorine chain or the carbon fluorine
bond in the environment is one of the
strongest in nature and so it's very
hard to degrade it's very hard to break
down um so for the purposes of the stock
we're going to imagine it's like a steel
chain so it's very hard to move it's
hard to break it doesn't want to
interact with other things but then that
polar head group is going to act as an
interactive surface and so it's going to
sort of interact with any material you
put it up against it's actually
hydrophilic
whereas the carbon fluorine chain is
hydrophobic
so these chemicals have very unique
properties in the environment and they
are in lots of different sectors so
let's talk about how they end up in the
environment and how they're all
connected so we put together a nice
little web this is not all-inclusive so
they're certainly different little
offshoots here so i've just sort of
broken it down in simplistic terms so
firstly we have manufacturing
manufacturing can include just making
the pfast but also using and
manufacturing processes such as chrome
plating for mis-suppression
the other place we're gonna go once
we've manufactured is consumer products
so the next time you go to buy a
waterproof jacket or stain resistant
shirt know that you're probably
purchasing pfas um when we wash these
products
typically um though
there is the potential that pfas could
be washed off they go into the
wastewater stream in the form of gray
water and then they're transported to
your local wastewater treatment plant
once they reach your wastewater
treatment plant pfas tend to distribute
both into the biosolids and into they
stay in the in the water um so
just a stop point here so the biosolids
have the potential um at a certain point
to be distributed to the landfill so we
have a little bit of crosstalk between
land cells and wastewater treatment
plants um so just something to keep in
mind but then that finished effluent may
have pfas in them uh or in it and so the
pfas may be distributed to the
groundwater surface water and drinking
water and we're going to talk about that
that sort of endpoint here in just a
second but it's important to keep in
mind
so back to our consumer products we wash
them we love them they end up at the
wastewater treatment plant and then at
the end of the garment slay for the
product's life we'll throw them away so
once they hit the landfill um that
the landfill is actually serving as an
aggregate for pfats but we also have to
keep in mind that there is a liquid
content typically associated with
landfill and as that percolates down
that's called lancoliche and that
distributes at the bottom it's then
collected and in some cases it's
recirculated um because it's full of
good microbial growth and so it's going
to help break down things further in the
landfill alternatively that lambda
leachate is taken directly to the
wastewater treatment plant where it is
bled into the wastewater treatment plant
stream
so you can see there's lots of crosstalk
between these two sources um and in that
way so we could have the landfill
leachate that's led into the wastewater
treatment plant or potentially leaks in
the landfills um and that could be
contributing to groundwater surface
water and drinking water contamination
of pfas
so our other major source is going to be
aqueous film forming foam application
and use uh so this is actually a photo
out of a naval ship and so
they're very specialized products
they're for hydrocarbon-based fuels and
in some cases polar solvent fires um
they're not going to be your common
everyday uh
aqueous film forming foam um
uses but they're going to be used for
specific purposes so there's plane crash
there's a train crash and so of course
we use a trip left to put out a fire
quickly and um there that's a specific
event but the other thing we have to
consider is fire training areas so
historically we've needed to train our
firefighters right how to use these
products and so with fire training areas
typically what will happen is
historically there was a lined pit you
would add fuel you would put the fire
out with the a triple f
and that e triple f was uncontained and
so it would percolate down into the
groundwater surface water where it has
the potential to impact drinking water
of course once we realize this is truly
an environmental issue uh new measures
have been taken where a lot of that um
products will be removed and actually
plumbed over to your local wastewater
treatment plant
so something to keep in mind of course
there's lots of crosstalk and we have
environmental distribution of pfas
coming from different sources so just to
give you a little bit a little bit of
context
okay so you'll notice i kept talking
about drinking water okay so there is
some regulation for pfas in the united
states so there are currently uh there
is a health advisory limit set by the
uscpa of 70 nanograms per liter for pfos
and pifoa or combination of the two
typically we see these things these two
chemicals co-occur um so the likelihood
is it's going to be a summation of phos
and pixoa and not one or the other
although those cases do exist
um so you can see the chemical
structures over here for those of you
that are interested on the right hand
side um so p follower has a carbon
fluorine chain length of seven and p
phos has a carbon chain length of eight
the reason that cutoff was set is
because that is typically where we see
um negative bioaccumulation happening um
and potentially health effects so you'll
note that these are health advisory
limits and they're in drinking water
only so we're going to talk about that
in just a second but it here it's really
important to remember that these are
health advisory limits and not maximum
contaminant levels which means that
they're not enforceable
so this is because they were set on
non-cancer endpoints including reduced
birth weight in pfas and developmental
effects and bones and accelerated
puberty and pisa
however i should note that there is
increasing interest at state and federal
levels and so those limits or those
the health advisory limits may be
variable depending on your state so i
highly recommend if you're interested to
go look at your state's
legislature and find out what the health
advisory
limit is
okay so we talked more about drinking
water and so how impacted is our
drinking water so we know right now that
drinking water is a huge exposure vector
to pfos and phoenix and pfas in general
um so if you are a member of the general
public typically your largest exposure
is going to be drinking water um as part
of the uscpa uh third unregulated
contaminant monitoring role program
which is always one of my favorite
examples we've actually included six p
fasts so including t-fos and fifo which
are those health advisory limit
chemicals um and they found that roughly
six million people in the us exceeded
that epa health advisory of 70 nanograms
per liter and they found further if you
lived within a military watershed you
had a 10 to 35 percent increase risk to
exposure uh so something sort of to keep
in mind we want to protect our natural
resources and how do we do that we have
to think about you know good
measurements and how to uh effectively
measure them i'm just going to point out
over here on the right there is a
fabulous website called the
environmental working group i highly
recommend you check that out it's
actually an interactive map that's full
of contamination so when there has been
measurements made it'll be posted to
this website you can sort of hover over
so you can look at your local area i
always think it's pretty fancy and
recommend you check it out
okay so we know there is regulation we
know that there is potential
contamination and so this is where nist
steps in
so nist is the north american metrology
institute which is where i'm currently
doing my postdoc and nist is responsible
for standard reference materials so
standard reference materials are used
for
a number of different reasons including
to calibrate a measurement system to
establish traceability of measurements
to validate an analytical system and to
provide quality control of measurements
so you can see over here as some
pictures on the right of different srm
materials the standard reference
material
and we're going to be talking a little
bit about that
and sort of my journey to being able to
quantitatively measure standard
reference materials for pfas
if you're interested a little bit more
and how srms have been used historically
uh jessica rainer and i published a
paper earlier this year you can see the
the little crop of it down here in the
left-hand corner but it is a case study
looking at how the environmental
community has used a standard reference
material in their measurements um so if
you're interested and you'd like to
follow up feel free to reach out to any
of us or check out that paper first
okay so specifically at nist
we currently have 10 standard reference
material with measured pfas in them so
you can see the list here we've got some
fish tissues some human serum house dust
soil domestic sludge and just neat
materials in methanol if you're
interested go ahead and follow that link
there and you can look into what
measurements have been made and what
they are so ultimately the the benefit
of an accessor is you know what the
concentration is and you know what the
matrix is so it's helping provide a
better calibration measure um to
increase the quality of the measurements
we make
okay so talking a little bit more about
those materials
i wanted to sort of take everyone
through a journey of my experience at
nist um so as i i sort of talked about
earlier i started in pfas and i had the
opportunity when i moved to nist to
start working on a new pfas methodology
or a few new pfas methodology one for
liquid chromatography mass spectrometry
and one for gas chromatography mass
spectrometry so the later part of this
talk is going to be discussing
everything that i've sort of gone
through to optimize
so thinking first about our materials
i wanted to give you an example so this
is going to be a graphic example and
then i'll give you uh just a visual
picture of how pfast works just to give
you a little bit more of an idea how
they interact with the surface
okay so imagine this is your lovely
material this could be paper textile it
could a food contact material a
waterproof jacket
and so as we sort of talked about there
was is that um big chain that doesn't
want to interact okay so i talked about
how pfast and that carbon fluorine chain
are hydrophobic they're oleophobic water
and oil repellent they don't want to
interact with anything so those carbon
fluorine tails are actually going to
stick straight up off of the surface
keeping in mind here there could be a
linear and branched isomers as i
mentioned before attached to the surface
and then that polar head group
that's going to interact with the
surface and so that polar hood group is
actually going to bind to the material
and this is how like a teflon pan works
or your waterproof jacket so we've got
these carbon flooring chains sticking up
and the polar head group attached to the
surface so when water and oil are
present they
don't they try and uh get repelled by
the carbon fluorine chain and the water
and oil bounces right off so that's why
that's so effective just to give you a
visual representation so this is a
material that has one side coated in
pfas
so on the bottom so this is the side
chain 4 polymer we know that it's made
of ptfe
so down here on the bottom picture you
can see or can't see um i actually
sprayed a bit of water on that side and
so you can see it just sort of like
blobs out and so you don't get a lot of
definition of where the water is however
on the p-pass coated side it's got all
those carbon flooring chains sticking up
and so what you get is that water that
really tries to just interact with
itself to get away from those carbon
fluorine chains because the carbon
fluorine genes are repelling the water
so i thought that was a great visual
representation it's always one of my
favorite and hopefully it helps you to
sort of put pfas into perspective
okay so we have our material the first
thing we need to do is extract the
material so this is a very brief uh
overview and if you have any questions
feel free to reach out there are lots of
people doing amazing work with all of
these different matrices um i've covered
just a couple of different ways the pfas
can be extracted so a typical extraction
could consist of solid phase extraction
so you would do isotope dilution here in
the first step you would add in your
solid phase extraction attach to an sda
manifold and elude it you may blow it
down to concentrate the pfas material in
there and then you would transfer it to
an auto sampler vial for analysis
the alternative you could do a dilution
series where you would take a small
aliquot out of your bottle you would add
internal standards and you would put
that directly in your auto sampler vial
so depending on the concentration it has
to be fit for a purpose
there are of course other tons of other
types of extractions including liquid
liquid extraction and other which could
encompass really anything your heart
sort of desires um so here's just one
example um again i'm going to talk about
our nice little material
so imagine that we've got that down to
the surface again now i'm going to add
solvent and carry away what is missable
so just to put that for you one more
time and it carries it away so
what we're interested in is really what
is coming off of materials or coming
through materials through the extraction
proc process and could potentially be
available for exposure to humans
okay so now we've extracted our material
we put it in an auto sampler vial and
now we have to run it through an
analytical method so this is sort of the
fun part for me i love method
development so that's what i'll be
talking about today so we're first going
to start with liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry um i got started here at
nist as i mentioned in november in about
february i was given access to an
instrument instrument and able to divine
to develop my pfas method so the first
thing i had to think about was what
analytes did i want to include so
because lcm sms is a targeted approach
meaning that i have to tell the
instrument specifically what to look for
i needed to know what to look for so
this
included a large literature dive and
relying on previous knowledge to select
the analytes of interest so i say fit
for purpose because uh if you were
looking for an a triple f source versus
a groundwater source versus a consumer
product you may actually look for
different pfas in the environment um so
something to keep in mind make sure that
the analytes you're selecting are ones
that are specific to your matrix um so
the next thing i did is i went out into
the great world and i
purchased standard reference materials
or i'm sorry not standard reference
materials commercially available
standard materials that um are just pure
pfas so
there are many different sources
including wellington tci lots of
different places and they all sell
different products so i purchased from
there they're neat materials and then i
had to infuse those materials so the
purpose behind this is to optimize in
the instrument so
the mass spec is trying to look for
these chemicals and you want to make
sure that when it's looking for that
little snapshot it can see everything it
possibly can see to the best of its
ability so this could be things like um
depolarization energy exit potential
collision energies collision voltages um
so it's all going to be very dependent
on the instrumentation so i've listed my
parameters here um but it may it's of
course going to vary instrument
instrument
so the other thing i did was optimize
sort of i'm calling it at the macro
scale which is not the correct language
by any means but it's the overall
parameters that are set forth by the
instrument that impacts the entire
method so it's not analyte specific but
it's method specific and so that's this
table over here on the right so the
example of instrument ionization or
optimization i apologize um so okay now
my mass spec is tuned it's super happy
it can see everything hopefully that
it's looking for um the next thing we're
going to have to do is separate out of
our samples and so we're going to do
that by selecting an analytical column
so
uh over here on the left i have sort of
a step by step step by step of things
that i needed to
purchase in order to build my analytical
method of course everyone has different
opinions go ahead and take a look in the
literature people have lots of different
ideas on what columns and things to use
i'm just going to briefly talk about a
few things that i found very useful and
products that i tended to use so that we
can compare later on uh so the first
thing was an analytical hold up column
so i purchased an eclipse plus c18
essentially what this does is this goes
after it goes after your purge valve and
it's going to filter out all the pfas
that may be coming from upstream of your
sample so that are resident in the
liquid chromatography side of things so
on your lc stack um
typically because these are in
everything they're in seals they're in
your degassers they're in a couple
different places i've seen this to be
especially prevalent if it's a new
instrument um you may have background
contamination so rather than
artificially inflating your uh
concentrations that you get out of your
sample um you can put on this delay
column and what it will do is shift your
contamination to slightly later in your
analytical run so that there is
separation between your peak and your
con and your contamination peak um so
it's kind of important it's very
important for this method and i highly
encourage that you use it um something
that's sort of optional but i've gotten
a lot of value out of um is an
analytical guard cartridge so i selected
a doorback style
depending again this is fit for purpose
so i have a sort of weak link in my
methodology and so that's psva so that's
such short chain carboxylic acid c4 um
which we're going to talk about here in
two slides
but i wanted to include that dial here
um specifically for sort of my my
problem children of the analytical
methodology so the last thing you're
going to need and perhaps the most
important is going to be your actual
analytical column
so you'll notice here i've listed three
different ones so we see a teen a pfp
and a phenylhexyl column
so these are all analytical columns that
can perform the
chromatographic separation that we may
need
the next thing you're going to do once
you've purchased your column is going to
be set up an analytical gradient and
choose a mobile phase
so here i've listed an example of what i
use and then the gradient over here on
the right so you'll notice that the
gradient varies slightly depending on
the column and so that's just to get the
chromatographic separation that i i'm
desiring and so this was the final
methodology of course there was some
tweaking
that i sort of went through as i was
developing these methods and feel free
to uh use this try it out um shoot me an
email if you have any questions
but okay so we run a standard now we're
going to have a mixture i actually had a
mixture of 34 individual pfas analytes
uh i injected them into my
instrumentation using just dilution at
15 nanograms per ml in methanol um and
so you'll see the different
configurations so i used the doorback
style on all three of my different
methods with varying
analytical columns so over here on the
left is the c18 configuration the
phenylhexyl configuration and the pft
configuration
you'll notice there's there's peaks
which is great um but we need to dig in
a little bit more so what you're looking
at is the total ion chromatogram it's
representing all of the peaks that are
eluting and being collected by the mass
spectrometer but they're not super
helpful for selectivity because we can't
see everything individually quite yet
so let's dive a little bit deeper um
first we need to compare our chroma
chromatography across three different
analytical columns so on the left hand
side you can see the three different
configurations so there's the c18 the
funnel hexel and the pfd so as i
mentioned pfva is one of the trickier
ones because it's so small um relatively
speaking molecular weight wise
it tends to slip through an analytical
column more quickly there's less there's
less good retention um and so what
you'll end up with is variable peak
shapes so you'll notice uh a and c here
nice and gaussian peak shapes that's
sort of what we would expect and in b
which is the funnel hexel you see a
little bit of tailing so of course it's
acceptable but it's not perfect and
we're aiming for perfection here so um
right now my contenders i'm thinking
would be a or c so that's the 18 or the
psp column
so let's pick a different analyte so
something else that's going to be kind
of troublesome and we want to make sure
it's included in our chromatography and
so that's the branch in linear isomers
as they sort of talked about earlier
they have a smaller overall size because
of that branching and so that's
represented here chromatographically as
this earlier uh sort of hump on the
front end of our chromatography they
move through the system slightly faster
and so they elude sooner um
in current methods we want to quantify
both branched and linear but we like to
have that branch in linear separation so
that was something i was looking for
when i was creating this method uh
you'll notice here in a we get nice
resolution between branched and linear
um so we're like in the looks of that so
far and b with the final hacksaw there
is separation but it's not baseline
result and so i say baseline results is
there are two individual peaks between
the branched and the linear we didn't
quite get that it's still it's not bad
but it could be better um and then with
c we have actually either more
separation um or not perfect resolution
between the branch and linear and so for
that reason i ended up selecting
the dial connected to that c18 column
and feel free to grab that information i
really like this column it's been very
stable i've run probably 1500 samples on
it at this point and it's still going
strong
okay so the last thing we have to do we
finalize our method we're happy with our
chromatography we're happy with our
optimization the last thing we do is we
put it into action um so below i sort of
described an experiment where i was
evaluating different bulk solvent phases
um four efficiency absorbing t-fast from
synthetic ground water so you'll notice
um the measurements are very close to
one another those rsd values are quite
low so the reason for that we are the
metrology institute so all of our
measurements are made gravimetrically
which means that there's reduced error
um versus doing things volumetrically so
something to consider but uh we were
quite happy with the results you'll
notice here actually so pfca which we
know is our sort of problem child um
that we didn't get good retention um so
the concentration is below my reporting
limit and the reason for that is is
actually the sorbent and not the
analytical method we know that because
we could just see it with our analytical
description so something to keep in mind
just because you don't see it doesn't
mean that it's a problem with your
analytical setup you want to validate
your analytical setup
before you sort of dive into your
samples
okay so we've gone through the liquid
chromatography side now let's briefly
talk about gas chromatography so gas
chromatography was new to me i was
really excited about it um so i'm going
to sort of walk you through the steps of
developing us developing a method here
so the big difference between lc
analytes and gcm lights are going to be
how generally how volatile they are in
the environment um so
the more volatile analytes are going to
be
preferentially selected for gc whereas
the ionic or less volatile analytes are
going to be selected for lcm sms there
is a little bit of cross talk between
the two of those but i'm not going to
discuss that really today so again we
have to start at the beginning so what
analytes do we want to include um so we
one want to make sure that we're
selecting the correct analyze so the
volatile analytes and ones that are
appropriate for our matrix so something
to keep in mind
okay so gas chromatography versus liquid
chromatography we're going to be
starting things a little bit differently
because there is no way to infuse we
first have to purchase a column and
get separation so
the way i did that was i went into the
literature i talked to less people who
are gc experts and i selected some
columns so in this case i again have a
guard column and that's just going to be
for analytical separation um a connector
between the two and then an analytical
column it's actually selected an rtx vms
column from restek
it's a great column i've really enjoyed
it so far it is a proprietary blend but
i suspect it primarily works off with
hydrophobicity which is going to be to
our benefit here and we'll discuss that
in a second
um
but so now we have our analytical column
the important thing that we need to know
is the boiling point of our analytes so
i mentioned hydrophobicity
and the reason for that is most of the
illusion is going to be a result of
boiling point plus the interaction with
the stationary phase in your analytical
column
so to start and to get that initial
chromatographic separation i wanted to
go
slow and steady and so i did that by
creating a very slow ramp
all the way up to the maximum of my
column where i held it just to get off
any extra contaminants that could be in
there so over here on the right you can
see the representation of my method my
temperature gradient
okay so we've run our low and flow
method and now i'm
using analytical standards we're going
to set up a sim scan method which is uh
the selection that you would put in your
graph your gcms
and we want to include the m over z
range of your analyte so we need to
again it's targeted so we need to make
sure that we know what we're looking for
um then we're going to identify ions and
build a sim method for the most abundant
ions um and so i've create i've included
a picture over here on the right but
it's kind of hard to see so let's dive
in a little bit more see what i mean by
that so i've taken an example which is
the this is the h2 for telomere alcohol
or f2 um in sim scan mode so i've
included my uh my total ion chromatogram
scan with my m over z that was including
the http f2 range and you see we've got
a nice peak here so if i scroll over
that peak and i look at the spectra
that's coming off of it you'll see all
of these little peaks and so these are
the ions that i'm going to select and
test for inclusion in my methodology
okay so you'll notice that there are
some sort of smaller peaks over here on
the
higher mass m over z range master charge
uh
over on the i'm sorry on the right
however on the lower end you get higher
abundance but less selectivity so the
reason for that is because this is uh
typically more of a hard ionization
technique
you're going to get more
mass over on the left side at the lower
range so we're going to include mostly
the high end mass range but
not going to completely include or
exclude our low end mass range so just
something to keep in mind
okay so now i've selected my ions that
are directly related to my h2fto
and then i'm going to come back and i'm
going to build a sim mrm method with
those specific ions and i'm going to try
and select the most abundant ions
okay so how do we do that um so you'll
notice that 445 the 406 and 464 were all
in my selected ions off of our h2so
example from a few slides ago and now i
ran them i looked at the total abundance
you'll see that 445 was selected as my
quantitative ion because it's the most
abundant 406 is my qualitative ion
because it's slightly less abundant and
464 was actually emitted from the method
because it's less abundant um so it
would be a good backup in case my 406 or
445 end up having a
interference that's coming out of our
matrix
okay so the one of the last things we
need to do is adjust our analytical
temperature gradient for our desired
chromatographic separation um so
over here we have the four to two five
to two f two and that's on the left hand
side and our first window and so what i
i had a bit of trouble resolving between
the two because they are quite uh close
in molecular weights and so i separated
them out a bit using just a hold so this
purple line on the or the temperature
gradient and then uh you'll notice the
six and the seven to two i created sort
of a slow ramp right there at the
beginning
just to get that nice separation so
something to keep in mind even though we
are selecting for the specific ions
last thing we need to do is define our
windows for increased sensitivity so you
can see these little gray bars with
arrows so those are my individual
windows this just helps to weed out the
noise and reduce the amount of scans
that the instrument is doing per second
so the last thing we have to do now that
we have our happy method is to apply the
method i'm currently in the process of
extracting srm materials and i'll have
more data for you soon
and with that i just wanted to wrap up
thank you so much for your time and
attention feel free to reach out if you
have any additional questions